hi my name is larry summers my name is
Steve Pinker
my name is Tamar Gendler my name is Leon
Botstein my name is Professor Michio
Kaku
I think information technology will make
a very big difference in education great
thinkers think not only about questions
central to the discipline but also about
how those questions relate to the fields
around them what I want to do today is
talk about the field of psychology we
physicists invented the laser beam we
invented the transistor we helped to
create the first computer economics is
yeah it's about making money but it's
about human behavior in general there's
something special it's something weird
almost about groups of individuals about
collectivities something weird that you
cannot see if you just study individuals
stock market the short term is what we
call a voting machine it really
represents the whims of people and the
short term this is a population pyramid
it's one of the basic descriptive tools
of demography and you should understand
what it is for the past twenty four
centuries very few thinkers in the
Western tradition have been able to
avoid having to come at some point to
grips with Socrates any sentence that
you producer understand is a brand new
combination produced for the first time
perhaps in your life perhaps even in the
history of the species but much of art
and much of the art that leaked of care
about responds to something other than
the linguistic there's an excitement
about scientific discovery which is like
practically nothing else I've had
life